und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
[Musik]
einen guten abend hinein am ende einer
woche mit schlagzeilen die selbst für
professionelle nachrichten übermittler
nicht leicht zu fassen sind angriffe auf
atomanlagen auf schwangere auf
krebskranke kinder warnungen dass alles
vollends außer kontrolle geraten könnte
der us-präsident der sagt wir müssen
einen dritten weltkrieg verhindern dass
ich das hier mal eben so aufzähle ist ja
schon ein wahnsinn jede einzelne
nachricht für sich unvorstellbar und sie
sollte unvorstellbar seien eigentlich
wir zeigen ihnen in den kommenden 30
minuten schicksale und hintergründe wir
zeigen ihnen die bilder von heute nicht
wahllos alle die wir zeigen könnten die
die sie sehen sind furchtbar genug krieg
ist furchtbar der gegen die ukraine
verlagert sich zusehends richtung westen
näher heran auch an uns petra auto
berichtet
es ist krieg und es ist sonntag es wird
gekämpft und es wird gebetet auch hier
im st michaels kloster in kiew segnung
der waffen und der soldaten die dieses
land verteidigen sollen die geschosse
sie sollen nicht die bürger der ukraine
verletzten nur das böse sollen sie
treffen sagt der militärpfarrer
auch in rom gebete von höchster stelle
für diese barbarei kinder zu töten
unschuldige menschen und wehrlose
zivilisten gibt es keinerlei glaubhafte
strategische gründe im namen des herrn
hört auf mit diesem massaker
2187 tote meldet heute der bürgermeister
von mario pohl seit mehr als einer woche
kaum ein rauskommen aus diesem feuer
kessel
diese luftaufnahme zeigt eine vor kurzem
noch intakte siedlung jetzt dem erdboden
gleichgemacht vernichtung einer
großstadt
keine guten nachrichten auch aus der
ganz westlichen ecke der ukraine war ja
worauf dicht an polen nur 25 kilometer
von der grenze entfernt hat das
russische militär eine ukrainische
militärbasis angegriffen 35 tote
134 verletzte nach jetzigem stand
momentan sind 25 einschläge bekannt ob
es nur soldaten unter den verletzten
gibt nein der angriff galt eindeutig
unsere militärischen stützpunkt vor dem
krieg hatten wohl nato militärausbilder
an dieser basis gearbeitet hier
archivaufnahmen übungen und europäische
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine zu
attackieren damit hat er russland schon
länger gedroht
die verletzten des heutigen angriffs sie
wurden in die umliegenden krankenhäuser
gebracht so nahe an ein nato land hatte
sich russland bislang nicht gewagt mit
seinen bomben
morgen fallen sie vielleicht zehn
kilometer auf die andere seite der
grenze nach polen da wo unsere frauen
und kinder gerade sind und
so rückt die bedrohung wieder ein stück
mehr an diesem sonntag
die russischen angriffe jetzt
geografisch also sehr dicht dran an
polen einem nato staat florian hahn ist
unser nato korrespondent in brüssel
genannt florian wie alarmiert ist man
denn da jetzt und wie sieht der nato
plan aus für den fall dass bei so etwas
auch polnisches territorium getroffen
würde möglicherweise eben unabsichtlich
natürlich ist man sehr alarmiert bei der
nato manch ein wütendes sprach heute von
einer bedeutenden eskalationen seitens
russlands einerseits hat man bei der
nato die große sorge dass man irgendwie
in diesen krieg hineingezogen werden
würde da stünden sich dann diverse
atommächte gegenüber mit potenziell
verheerenden folgen das will die nato
zumindest auf jeden fall vermeiden
andererseits macht die nato heute erneut
deutlich man wird das gebiet der nato um
jeden zentimeter sozusagen kämpfen jeden
zentimeter verteidigen ein angriff auf
einen nato land das wäre ein angriff auf
alle dieser berühmte bündnisfall der
nato ob das nun auch bei einem
fehlgeleiteten beschuss wie von dir
christian angedeutet gelten wird das
wird man im einzelfall sich sehr genau
anschauen die möglichkeit aber die
besteht auf jeden fall wichtig ist
vielleicht noch zu sagen eine
klitzekleine gute nachricht es wurde mir
heute noch mal versichert die
militärischen gesprächskanäle kanäle
zwischen russland und der nato die
funktionieren weiterhin und darüber
hofft man so eine ungeplante eskalation
irgendwie verhindern zu können wir sind
dankbar für jede noch so klitzekleine
gute nachricht florian russland sagt
jetzt angriffe die angriffe heute hätten
einer militäranlage gegolten der
militärisches gerät gelagert gewesen sei
dass aus dem ausland an die ukraine
geliefert worden sei das ist ja dann
eine warnung das soll eine warnung sein
vor weiteren nato waffenlieferungen oder
ja eindeutig war mir auch gerade gehört
gestern bereits gab es die warnung des
stellvertretenden russischen
außenminister sergej rjabkow der sagte
auch künftig werde man solche
waffenlieferungen zum ziel von
russischen angriffen machen heute also
der beschuss ja in der tat haben ja
verschiedenen nato staaten in den
letzten tagen und wochen zahlreiche
waffen an die ukraine geliefert auch
sehr effektive waffen flugabwehrraketen
zum beispiel die mit ein grund dafür
sein dürften dass dieser russische
vormarsch eben nicht so schnell
vonstatten geht die sich man vielleicht
im kreml gedacht hat aber
verschiedenen nato staaten haben bereits
gesagt sie wollen weiter waffen liefern
gestern war dass die aussage des us
präsidenten heute ganz aktuell der der
britische premier johnson ihrem gespräch
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten syriens
key aber es dürfte künftig schwerer
werden diese waffen auch zu übergeben
man könnte es dann zu dem kommen was wir
anfangs besprachen das risiko einer
offenen eskalation zwischen der nato und
russland florian vielen dank florian
haben war das live aus brüssel heute
abend
wir haben gestern hier in dieser sendung
mit einem notarzt in kiew gesprochen der
von menschenleeren wohnblocks dort
berichtete weit über zwei millionen
menschen sind auf der flucht viele
frauen und kinder
unterwegs mit kleinstem gepäck eine
tasche ein teddybär was man tragen kann
sie wissen warum sie gehen sie wissen
nicht wohin
der größte teil landet zunächst in polen
warschau hauptbahnhof von wo ein
videoclip die runde macht im internet
[Musik]
aktion dinosaurier nennt sich das
mitgefühl und hilfsbereitschaft sind
eben nicht ausgestorben
[Musik]
es ist die stunde der helfer auch in
berlin freiwillige die erkannt haben was
da passiert braucht unsere unterstützung
der hauptbahnhof vergangenen nacht er
ist zum drehkreuz der flüchtlinge
geworden in deutschland alissa jung ist
dort es wird gerade dunkle in berlin da
kommt schon wieder ein bus bringt
menschen aus der ukraine an den
hauptbahnhof müde kinder mit ihren mamas
tage lang sind sie gereist und müssen
sich nun zu recht finden
es kommen mehr an als wegfahren
eigentlich sollten busse heute menschen
weiter nach hannover bringen aber die
busse kamen nicht für die freiwilligen
helferinnen und helfer manchmal kaum
noch zu schaffen
irina ist in der ukraine geboren hilft
hier jeden tag schlafen kann sie sowieso
nicht mehr
tagsüber wenn die meisten züge kommen
sind viele freiwillige da oben am gleis
mischen sich normale reisende mit
menschen auf der flucht und den
helferinnen und helfern mit weste gelb
steht für ich spreche englisch orange
für ukrainisch und russisch beide
bedeuten ich helfe dir
helfer wie janosch unten im
zwischengeschoss ist ihre zentrale und
schaut auf alte leute und frauen mit
kleinkindern
sie haben ein still zelt aufgebaut und
eine ecke für kinder eine stolze starke
ukrainerin hat angelina geflohen aus ich
bin hier gemalt
stolz und stark wie nadia selbst gerade
erst aus odessa geflüchtet hilft sie
hier jeden tag ich möchte mich fühle als
als fluglinie außerdem gut ich bin ich
bin gesund im wind stark ich bin ja ich
bin ukraine ich kann nichts nur als ja
in meinem land ist es ist ja diese
situation aber ich bin nicht durch linie
ja ich möchte nicht hier bleiben blickt
nach meiner land da gehen und dann helfe
ich meinem land nun erklärt sie aber
zunächst anderen das fremde deutschland
inzwischen ist es abend geworden
lehramtsstudentin katja hilft seit einer
woche übernimmt heute die nachtschicht
und damit auch viel verantwortung nachts
sind sie weniger und in den letzten
tagen haben männer mehrfach versucht
junge frauen zum mitkommen zu überreden
seitdem pendelt aufgegriffen hat und in
business gucken was los und zu können
was ich heute nicht mehr aufklären lässt
der mann wurde nicht gefasst nur gesehen
aber es ist seit letzter nacht mehr
polizei und bvg sicherheit vor ort das
beruhigt zwar gibt es inzwischen auch
hilfe vom senat wie das catering und ein
wärmezelt doch noch immer sind die
freiwilligen erste anlaufstation
vor allem wenn um mitternacht noch zu
bekommen
es werden nun dringend schlaf plätze
gebraucht
für diese dreifach mama mit baby haben
sie heute nacht ein kostenloses hotel
gefunden andere kommen in diesem schlaf
zug unter
zumindest eine nacht ausruhen in ruhe
und frieden
krieg macht vor niemandem halt auch
nicht vor den schwächsten die die
sowieso leiden müssen leiden im krieg
noch mal besonders es ist nicht leicht
zu ertragen was uns viele basler jetzt
zeigt es bleibt der trost eine kleine
gruppe kranker kinder aus der ukraine
ist jetzt in sicherheit es bleibt die
aufgabe viele weitere von ihnen in
sicherheit zu bringen
melania ist sehr krank das zweijährige
mädchen hat krebs vor wenigen tagen sind
die eltern mit ihrer tochter aus kiew in
münchen angekommen hinter ihnen sagen
sie liegen
wir waren für behandlung im
kinderkrankenhaus auch magath dann
begann der krieg mit feuergefechten
luftangriffen bombardierungen von kiew
bei jedem sirenenalarm mussten sie und
andere familien mit ihren krebskranken
kindern in den keller dieser klinik aus
haaren liegen tage und nächtelang
dokumente ihrer verzweiflung
festgehalten auch von netz gehen dann
hielten sie es nicht mehr aus
wir haben die klinik verlassen wir
hatten einen minibus dann sind wir mit
müttern und sechs schwer kranken kindern
zur polnischen grenze gefahren und
hoffte nur dass die kinder es überleben
werden eine bange fata in eine ungewisse
zukunft zwei tage und nächte eine tortur
auch für melanie us mutter
es war kaum auszuhalten meine tochter
ist todkrank und dann noch der krieg all
das auf einmal es ist schwer zu
verkraften
seit einer woche werden melania und
sechs weitere kinder vom team des
haunerschen kinderspitals in münchen
behandelt soforthilfe ganz
unbürokratisch über alle grenzen hinweg
das sei höchste zeit gewesen so die
mediziner die kinder kommen alle
ausgezehrt durstig hungrig und mit ihrer
lebensbedrohlichen krebs erkranken
es ist bitter den zustand dieser kinder
zu sehen die zehn monate alte anna bekam
während der flucht hohes fieber 40 grad
ob das krebskranke kind überleben würde
schien fraglich doch seitdem der klinik
ist geht es langsam bergauf
alles was die kleine familie besitzt
trägt sie am leib weil ihr heimatort
bombardiert wurde konnten mutter und
vater wolodimir fast nichts mit niebel
wir haben jetzt nur noch uns ich habe
meine frauen sie hat mich und das
wichtigste was wir haben ist unser baby
aber sagt er wir werden es aushalten
weil wir es aushalten müssen
dann müssen sie jetzt auch ihre heimat
und alles zurücklassen ich bin überzeugt
dass sowohl die kinder als auch
natürlich die eltern schwer
traumatisiert sind das wichtigste sagt
larissa sei dass ihre tochter wieder
gesund wird und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass man uns hier
aufgenommen hat und dass die menschen in
diesem land so viel für uns tun die
soforthilfe für kleine patienten die
melania lebensnotwendig für die
schwächsten der schwachen in diesem
krieg
sie können den menschen in der ukraine
und denen auf der flucht helfen mit
einer spende zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe das
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und das
hier ist die bankverbindung de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 und alle
informationen auch im internet oder im
zdf text
und wir bleiben noch beim thema hanna
des weiteren nachrichten mehr als
120.000 menschen sind heute in
deutschland auf die straße gegangen und
haben ein ende des ukraine krieges
gefordert allein in der hauptstadt waren
es laut veranstaltern etwa 60.000 mit
laub blau gelben flaggen und plakaten
zogen sie vom alexanderplatz zur
siegessäule zu den demonstrationen
aufgerufen hatten gewerkschaften
friedensorganisationen und kirchen auch
in anderen städten protestierten
zehntausende wie hier in stuttgart
in der vergangenen nacht hat iran nach
eigenen angaben raketen auf die kurden
hauptstadt erbil im norden des irak
abgefeuert das kurdische
innenministerium erklärte dass der
angriff dem neubau des us-konsulats
gegolten habe und die raketen in einem
wohngebiet eingeschlagen seien
mindestens ein mensch so leicht verletzt
worden sein laut iran war das ziel einen
stützpunkt des israelischen
geheimdienstes als vergeltung für einen
mutmaßlich israelischen angriff in
syrien vor etwa einer woche der
gouverneur von erbil sagte wiederum es
gebe keinen israelischen stützpunkt in
der gegend
wir blicken auf die korona incidents und
da liegt deutschland im europäischen
vergleich nun an der spitze
das twitterte heute gesundheitsminister
lauterbach mit verweis auf daten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
laut dem robert-koch-institut liegt die
sieben tage incidents aktuell bei über
1.500 innerhalb eines tages kamen 146
1607 neuinfektionen hinzu dass in fast
30.000 mehr als vor einer woche
in deutschland ist jedes fünfte kind von
armut bedroht das geht aus der antwort
der bundesregierung auf eine anfrage der
linken im bundestag hervor deutliche
unterschiede gibt es zwischen den
bundesländern
in bremen sind 42 prozent der kinder und
jugendlichen
armutsgefährdet in bayern sind es rund
zwölf prozent als arm gilt wer weniger
als 60 prozent des mittleren
haushaltseinkommens zur verfügung hat
dieser krieg kann russland für
jahrzehnte ins abseits stellen das zitat
stammt interessanterweise von wladimir
potanin einem steinreichen russischen
metall oligarchen der vielleicht vor
allem angst hat dass seine villen und
yachten ins abseits geraten aber fakt
ist die russischen angriffe die immer
stärkere repressionen gegen jeden der
auch nur wagt das wort krieg in den mund
zu nehmen und die westlichen sanktionen
hinterlassen tiefe spuren bei 140
millionen russen die russen
kenner des landes sagen sätze die einem
so schnell nicht wieder aus dem kopf
gehen 30 jahre wirtschaftlicher
integration russlands mit dem westen
sind in zwei wochen kaputt gegangen
russland steht vor einer umwälzung die
generationen prägen wird simon hrubesch
hat sich das genauer angesehen
streit um die letzte panne bei ikea ob
es nun die pfanne ist der burger bei
mcdonalds oder das letzte kleid bei zara
fielen in russland wurde in den letzten
tagen klar dass das leben wie sie es
gewohnt waren anders wird
ich bin selbstständig als meine christin
da brauche ich bestimmte tische und
arbeitsplatten das ist etwas das einfach
jeder braucht
sie haben nicht bekommen was wir suchten
weil es nichts mehr gibt
der rubel ist innerhalb weniger tage nur
noch halb so viel wert die preise sind
nach oben geschnellt und so wird
gehortet was es zu horten gibt in vielen
supermärkten ist die abgabe deshalb
limitiert
wir mussten uns für eine
außergewöhnliche maßnahmen entscheiden
verkaufs restriktionen einzuführen weil
menschen hast dich anfingen lebensmittel
zu kaufen wir haben die monats menge an
zucker innerhalb von zwei tagen verkauft
bereits über 320 internationale firmen
haben seit kriegsbeginn ihren rückzug
aus russland bekanntgegeben
auch mcdonald's dessen einzug 1992 als
symbol für die integration russlands in
den westen gefeiert wurde nun
geschlossen warum die firmen russland
verlassen viele verstehen es nicht
dieses verhalten ist einfach nur
unangebracht ich verstehe einfach nicht
warum sie das tun
das ist wirklich hart dass so viele ihre
jobs verlieren die situation ist
belastend und ich hoffe dass bald alles
wieder normal wird
eine schnelle rückkehr zur normalität
eher unwahrscheinlich
der ehemalige präsident medwedjew und
vertraute putin schreibt auf facebook
ganz unabhängig von den gründen der
abwanderung die rückkehr in unsere
märkte wird nicht leicht werden
51 millionen nutzer hat instagram in
russland seit der sperrung durch die
russischen behörden vor zwei tagen nur
noch eine fehlermeldung
youtube funktioniert noch hier zum
beispiel erklärt der blogger varlamov
die man das land verlässt in fünf tagen
hatte das video 25 millionen aufrufe 1
kommentar darunter es ist leicht zu
sagen wohin man gehen soll wenn wir nur
das geld hätten könnten wir überall
hingehen
putin entzieht vielen menschen innerhalb
weniger tage die basis trend was sich
über lange zeit verbunden hat die
leidtragenden sind die menschen in der
ukraine und in russland
allein nach georgien sind mehr als
25.000 russinnen und russen bereits
ausgereist es ist ein wahrer brain drain
und es sind vor allem viele junge
menschen auffallend viele
computertechniker bei den
regierungskritischen russischen
fernsehsender dort hat man over
gearbeitet bis der geschlossen wurde
auch sie ist jetzt in georgien frau
smirnova guten abend
wie sind sie zu dem entschluss gekommen
zu diesem schweren entschluss ihrer
heimat russland erst mal zu verlassen
also ganz kurz es gab einen so meeting
bei uns mit meinen kollegen von dort und
da haben wir alle beschlossen dass es
jetzt nicht mehr sicher für uns in
russland wäre und dass wir unsere arbeit
nicht so weitermachen könnten deswegen
haben so meisten von uns entschieden
unsere häuser zu verlassen ich auch eine
sehr schwierige abwägung kann ich mir
vorstellen auch eine sehr schwere frage
natürlich erstmal für jeden persönlich
jetzt haben sie gesagt
fast alle ihrer kollegen von von diesem
fernsehsender von dem
regierungskritischen fernsehsender sind
jetzt gegangen
das sind ja ausgerechnet die die
vielleicht versuchen könnten im land
etwas zu ändern gerade die die russland
jetzt bräuchte wie oft machen sie sich
diese gedanken
gucken sie mal wir sind wir hier jetzt
in der ungefähr
45 meine kollegen und ich wohne zusammen
mit drei von d sowie worden so fährt
weil es nicht so einfach gleich eine
wohnung zu finden
und ich kann so ehrlich sagen dass wir
jeden tag weinen und
miteinander besprechen ob es eine
richtige entscheidung war
wir besprechen auch wenn man sie zurück
nach hause kommen können alle vermissten
gehäuse und alle wollen zurück bestimmt
dann reden wir nochmal über irland über
russland ich habe vorhin einen experten
zitiert der sagte was wir da jetzt sehen
das ist eine epochale
transformation eines riesenlandes die
generationen prägen wird das ist ja ein
ganz großer satz versuchen was
vielleicht ein bisschen konkreter mal zu
machen alle
847 mcdonald's filialen in russland sind
erstmal zugemacht worden das wird jetzt
kein problem sein essen kann man auch
woanders aber welches signal kommt denn
damit bei den menschen in russland
dadurch an ich kann für meine familie
sahen meine familie die ganze meine
familie ist gegen krieg und
aber ich habe
viele videos
durch instagram telegramm gesehen wo
leute in russland feiern
die feiern was jetzt passiert die denken
wirklich dass es nicht einen krieg ist
sondern wie nennen es eine
sicherheits operation in der ukraine und
die denken das ist wirklich wahrheit ist
die folgen also dem präsidenten und
seiner propaganda in der hinsicht
sie denn dass diese menschen von denen
sie jetzt gerade gesprochen haben also
die die putin folgen dass die sich davon
abbringen lassen wenn sie jetzt kein
iphone mehr benutzen können wenn sie
nicht mehr auf instagram posten können
zeigt das wirkung bei denen
ich glaube jetzt noch nicht aber es
kommen gleich vielleicht in ein paar
wochen in drei wochen
eine frau die
wird das 100 prozent nachvollziehen dass
das leben sich geändert hat sagt maffay
smirnova journalisten gewesen bei einem
regierungskritischen fernsehsender in
russland was mir noch mal herzlichen
dank für das gespräch heute abend
und das gespräch aber aus technischen
gründen kurz vor dieser sendung
aufgezeichnet vor ein paar wochen stand
mavs mit einer war noch als moderatorin
in einem studio wie diese mehr und
befragte experten ob ein krieg drohe
jetzt steht auch ihr leben auf den kopf
nochmal hanna und zwar mit fußball in
der bundesliga gab es heute nämlich
gleich vier begegnungen rheinischen
derby verlor leverkusen gegen den ersten
fc köln mit 0 zu 1 eintracht frankfurt
und der vfl bochum trennten sich 2 2 1
dortmund holte sich drei punkte mit
einem 1 zu 0 gegen arminia bielefeld und
kräuter führt unterlag deutlich 1 zu 6
gegen rb leipzig hertha bsc hat einen
neuen trainer felix magath soll den
posten bis zum ende der saison
übernehmen und die berliner vor dem
abstieg retten magath folgt auf tayfun
korkut der nach der 0 2-pleite gestern
gegen mönchengladbach gehen musste
bilanz seiner kurzen amtszeit von nur 15
wochen zuletzt fünf niederlagen in folge
und der absturz auf den vorletzten
tabellenplatz
jetzt noch die wetteraussichten im
norden und der mitte ziehen morgen
dichte wolken mit regen durch sonst
wechseln sonne und wolken nur im
nordosten und ganz im südwesten bleibt
es den gesamten tag sonne ich die
höchstwerte erreichen 8 bis 16 grad die
weiteren aussichten am dienstag regnet
es bei 97 zehn grad vor allem in der
mitte danach wird es wieder sonnig und
trocken
lemberg wie flemm barrick eine stadt mit
so vielen namen muss etwas besonderes
sein wer einmal dort war im westen der
ukraine berichtet dieser ort lasse nicht
mehr los manche halten sie für die
schönste stadt europas zwischen 1914 und
45 hat lemberg nicht weniger als achtmal
besitzer und besatzer gewechselt in
lemberg lassen sich die größten
errungenschaften europas erspüren und
die grausamsten abgründe dem stadtbild
haben all die katastrophen des letzten
jahrhunderts nichts anhaben können über
zwei millionen touristen kamen zuletzt
jedes jahr jetzt kommt die angst dass
all die unersetzlichen kunstschätze
diesmal nicht verschont bleiben könnten
dass das erbe unzähliger völker und
kulturen in höchster gefahr ist dara
hassanzadeh ist in lemberg
die ukrainische hymne das ist ihre
antwort auf die luftschläge die menschen
in lemberg fordern moderne
luftabwehrsysteme jetzt sie sind hier
luftangriffen schutzlos ausgeliefert
ihre kunstschätze auch lemberg ist ein
unesco weltkulturerbe
alicia ist lehrerin in lemberg sie gibt
stadtführungen für flüchtlinge die sie
immer nur unsere gäste nennt alicia
hofft sie auf andere gedanken zu bringen
sie für kurze zeit abzulenken mit der
schönheit lembergs
es gelingt nur in ansätzen
möchte mich ablenken vom krieg ich
dachte es gelingt aber es gelingt
einfach nicht denn ich weiß wie es
aussieht den haag if und ich mache mir
sorgen um meine freunde
und um meine professoren die ich sehr
respektiere
ein wahrzeichen lembergs die welle der
nationalen wiedergeburt
1996 errichtet und aktuell wie nie
lembeck vereint die moderne mit der
architektur vergangener jahrhunderte
eroberer haben lemberg nicht zerstört
sondern häufig kulturelle spuren
hinterlassen ob habsburger polen oder
armenier
jenes zimmer haben wir dafür gesorgt
dass unsere kulturschätze erhalten
bleiben denkmäler und monumente
restauriert werden wir wertvollsten
unter ihnen haben wir an sichere orte
gebracht denn sie gehören nicht nur uns
sie gehören der ganzen welt
der stadtverwaltung gelang es in nur
sechs tagen fast alle kunstschätze in
sicherheit zu bringen
denkmäler die nicht abgebaut werden
können wurden so gut es geht verpackt
manche dieser werke wurden bereits
1939 vor den deutschen
nationalsozialisten versteckt
wenn ich beurteilen muss was jetzt in
der ukraine geschieht das ist
vergleichbar mit der zerstörung in
guernica in stalingrad und mit der
belagerung von leningrad die geschichte
wiederholt sich gerade mit all ihren
albträumen
vitali und seine frau versteckten sich
unter der treppe als ein geschoss ihr
haus traf sie haben es in kiew
zurückgelassen die angst jedoch
mitgenommen
die menschen in lemberg haben alles
getan um die kulturschätze zu retten
[Musik]
der menschenrechtsanwalt philippe sands
hat ein brilliantes buch geschrieben
darüber wie eng die erfahrungen von
lemberg seiner opfer und ankläger
verknüpft sind mit der entstehung des
völkerstrafrechts das uns normen gibt um
unvorstellbare verbrechen zu ahnden
wir werden auch nach diesem krieg auf
die erfahrungen von lemberg zurückkommen
und auf das völkerrecht
das war unsere welt an diesem sonntag
wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
guten abend und
jedes norbert mit dem feierlichen
abschluss der parallel ja eine bunte und
fröhliche finale show in peking trotz
der menschenrechtslage in china trotz
des krieges in der ukraine es war die
stunde der sportlerinnen und sportler
570 an der zahl aus 46 ländern die haben
in den letzten zehn tagen der ganzen
welt gezeigt dass man auch mit
behinderungen sportliche höchstleistung
erbringen kann die pc präsident andrew
parsons beschwor den geist der
paralympischen
[Musik]
wir trennen uns unterschiede nicht die
sie einen uns zusammen für eine
gemeinsame zukunft diese einigkeit gibt
uns hoffnung auf inklusion auf harmonie
und am allerwichtigsten hoffnung auf
frieden
für deutschland trugen die 18-jährige
goldmedaillengewinnerin leonie walter
und ihr guide firmen strecker die
schwarz-rot-goldene fahne
ja aus deutscher sicht waren das
durchaus erfolgreiche winterspiele 19
medaillen insgesamt darunter viermal
gold und platz sieben im
medaillenspiegel damit hatte das team
die erwartungen übertroffen marcel
bergmann
als die deutsche mannschaft mit 17
athleten und fünf guides zur
eröffnungsfeier in das vogelnest
-stadion einzog hatte man die
erwartungen so klein wie möglich
gehalten
umso größer natürlich die freude über
die erfolge allen voran von anna-lena
forster mit der man sich über zweimal
silber und zweimal gold freuen konnte
ich hoffe dass eben von diesen tollen
erfolgen auch die botschaft ausgeht an
junge menschen mit behinderung
körperlicher beeinträchtigung guckt mal
was da alle möglich ist was da möglich
ist zeigte die erst 15 jährige lin
katzmaier die in abwesenheit der starken
russen und peter russen allein fünf
medaillen zur deutschen bilanz
beisteuerte viermal edelmetall gewann
die auch erst 18 jahre alte leonie
walter zwei goldene versprechen für die
zukunft wir haben neun junge erst
starter dabei gehabt wir haben große
athletin zurücklassen müssen die
entweder aufgehört haben oder verletzt
waren und nicht mitkamen die
paralympischen winterspiele in peking
haben trotz aller politischen
fragwürdigkeit große lust gemacht auf
die kommenden spiele in mailand und
cortina d'ampezzo dann hoffentlich
wieder ohne corona und vor allem ohne
krieg
zum letzten mal einen blick auf den
medaillenspiegel china ja sowas von
souverän auf platz eins mit elfmal gold
und insgesamt 61 medaillen fast so viele
wie die ukraine kanada und frankreich
zusammen apropos ukraine die feiert mit
dem zweiten platz den bislang bestes
ergebnis bei paralympischen spielen und
das angesichts des kriegs in der heimat
eine belastung für die sportlerinnen
sportler aber auch für viele ansparen
gregory matschinsky zum beispiel der
heute mit der langlauf staffel gold
holte und der für die erfolge des
gesamten ukrainischen teams diese
erklärung hat
die ukraine muss auch in der zukunft
weiter existieren ich glaube das ist der
grund warum unser paralympisches team
das beste unserer geschichte war
die letzte goldmedaille dieser
paralympics wurde heute beim eishockey
vergeben an die usa die kanada im finale
mit 5 0 besiegte wir schauen jetzt auf
einen der kanadischen spieler auf sexy
wenn es gibt ja unglaubliche geschichten
die das leben wirklich schreibt und wenn
man die als film im kino sehen würde ja
dann geht so manchen der sagen würde
auch ja tolle story aber echt
übertrieben im typisch hollywood
alles echte geschichte von sec level wie
uns jetzt boris kramer erzählt
februar 2016 rocky mountains éclair wien
verliert sich auf einer tour durch die
wildnis
ich war irgendwo in den bergen ohne
orientierung drei tage lang suchte ich
den weg heraus aus schnee lovins handy
funktioniert nicht mehr sein körper
dehydriert und seine körpertemperatur
sinkt rapide
der damals 19-jährige schleppt sich
entkräftet auf eine abgelegene straße
ich dachte an meine familie ich wollte
einfach meine familie wiedersehen ich
musste weitermachen und sie wieder sehen
andere wanderer fanden mich schließlich
und holten hilfe
[Musik]
ins hände erholen sich doch seine beine
müssen oberhalb der knie amputiert
werden
eine starke familie hilft sehr im
fitnessstudio traf ich einen amputierten
der hockey spielte das wollte ich auch
probieren
mclaren auch als zweiter im hockey
finale heute ein gewinner und vorbild
fürs leben
das waren sie also die winter
paralympics in peking alles andere als
friedlichen zeiten die paralympische
flamme ist erloschen wieder entzündet
wird sie in vier jahren in mailand und
container cortina d'ampezzo danke für
ihr großes interesse an unserem
paralympischen sport blog im heute
journal und noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]